desde criança eu sempre fui muito
curioso é um doutor bob falou de biquíni
seja curioso acho que foi picado desde
pequenininho
é de se vestir bem
é então eu era daquelas crianças que
todo instante ficar perguntando por que
eu porque eu por que não aprender o meu
grande prazer até hoje se consegue
imaginar qual é o meu livro favorito
sempre foi o porquê das coisas é esse
livro é muito bacana porque ele pega um
transatlântico por exemplo em fátima no
meio e pra mim é incrível porque dava
para entender exatamente como funcionava
o navio por dentro na casa das máquinas
onde ficavam a a tripulação e os
passageiros né
então me deliciava e essa curiosidade
então era para tudo não só para coisas
mas para a vida para o mundo para a
natureza
talvez por isso eu tenho escolhido
engenharia e aí dentro das engenharias
eu fiz engenharia mecatrônica
no começo da década de 90 a engenharia
mais promissora juntava ii
a mecânica com a eletrônica com a
computação era um pouco o hardware junto
com o software é e então é essa aí
gerais que optei só que eu encontrei foi
um uma faculdade eniac no auge na década
de 90 do racionalismo científico do
pensamento onde privilegiava mente a
ciência por isso aqui de karts que foi
precursora e desse pensamento por vários
por vários séculos a e acho que atingiu
um ápice aí no final do do milênio
passado
eu acabei me frustrando acho que a
metáfora do que eu encontrei na
faculdade de engenharia é pelo menos pra
mim foi aqui um pouco do do homem de
lata então tinha toda a parte lógica
racional mas eu sentia falta de emoção
da parte do feeling é que foi comentado
aqui em diversas apresentações
então naquele momento o que existia isso
perdura
é uma transição imediata é a tecnologia
versus o homem é um pensamento de que o
homem é um ser incompleto há algumas
restrições de capacidade e que a
tecnologia permite é justamente superar
essas questões de capacidade do homem
então assim como era visto então
tecnologia sempre foi muito admirada
como fonte de progresso mas também muito
temida então aqui aqui um pouco do
imaginário cultural da questão da
tecnologia é um dos exemplos de filmes
que retratam então aí a tecnologia até
como ao que que mete medo preocupação
sobre o futuro até em uma hecatombe
nuclear essa hora não temáticas da
década de 80 década de 90
então dentro dessa dessa separação entre
homem e tecnologia e eu acabei em dupla
ao lado do homem
então não é que me formei na faculdade
mas acabei trabalhando em marketing
depois em publicidade ou seja fui
trabalhar com o comportamento humano
comportamento das pessoas
então eu acabei demorando afastando
totalmente o lado da tecnologia não
pegava em uma calculadora e foi então
justamente me aprofundar essa questão
mais de sentimento e emoção
então até que em um termo pro trabalho
que eu faço porque marketing
publicitário não é tão bem visto
então acho que o cheque é definir melhor
o que é o que o meu trabalho é
basicamente estudar profundamente o
impacto das transformações culturais
novos valores emergentes ou seja tudo
quem está falando aí de transformação da
sociedade
só que conforme eu fui mergulhando em
comportamento é uma coisa interessante
começou a surgir que foi o fato de
tecnologia cada vez mais presente na
nossa vida e cada vez mais influenciado
o comportamento então quanto mais eu
estudava comportamento mas na verdade eu
tinha que também entender a questão de
tecnologia então isso foi muito muito
interessante até que eu fui
há muito em função disso um evento em
austin no texas chamado o salto mais
alto este é um evento aí de dez dias
fecha cidade 50 mil pessoas mais de mil
palestras
as palestras acontecem espalhada sair
por 10 locações diferentes pela cidade e
que hoje é uma hora evento então de
interatividade do mundo
o que é interessante também desse evento
é que ele não é só de digital de
interatividade mas ele une cinema e
também em música então é super bacana
todos os os barzinhos enchem de bandas
do mundo inteiro então um ambiente super
rico que junta aí o lado artístico com a
tecnologia então hoje é um dos lugares
mais interessantes vai recomendo que que
todos possam algum momento participar
rola em março todo ano a e fui lá então
pra ver que está acontecendo no mundo no
futuro nesse cruzamento entre tecnologia
e ea vida das pessoas então é porque a
gente vai lá é porque o futuro já chegou
e só tá mal distribuído e é nesse tipo
de evento que justamente então a gente
consegue vislumbrar o que vai acontecer
nas nossas vidas aí nos próximos cinco
dez anos
aí o que eu vi lá esse ano eu chamei de
humanização da tecnologia
então o que estou percebendo é que a
tecnologia vem se transformando a tal
ponto que ela vem se humanizando e aí eu
tô conseguindo conciliar então aquela
questão dada a divisão aí entre entre as
pessoas ea tecnologia
eu vou explicar um pouco cheguei em
quatro princípios dessa organização e eu
vou trazer algumas referências para
vocês
então a primeira delas são as
tecnologias em prática sem empatia
quando você se coloca no lugar do outro
você entende o outro e é isso que vem
acontecendo com as tecnologias a
tecnologias cada vez mais sabem sobre a
vida de todo mundo tem mais informações
sobre sobre nós
então se eles devem conhecer a questão
do air bus que não é só o google glasgow
o novo é relógio da apple
no futuro a gente vai está vestindo
diversos sensores pelo todo o nosso
corpo justamente por aí colhendo esses
dados para que a tecnologia conhece
então nosso nosso comportamento
mas o que a gente o que que eu pude
perceber lá é que não são soldados
fisiológicos né
no final que a tecnologia quer descobrir
é justamente são as emoções o que a
gente está sentindo é isso que os
grandes cientistas os inovadores estão
trabalhando é para que a tecnologia
possa tomar são muito mais adequada de
acordo com a nossa emoção então está
surgindo todo um campo chama affective
computing é como se fosse uma computação
afetiva que é justamente identifica a
nossa emoção a todo momento então tem
desde roupa que vai mudar de cor vai
mudar de forma de acordo com o que a
gente está sentindo naquele momento e
vão existir aplicativos aí que vou ficar
o tempo inteiro é fazendo esse
rastreamento é um aparelho que foi
apresentado e que é super recente é o
muse é como se fosse um pequeno
eletroencefalograma portátil
então basicamente que a tecnologia quer
começar efetivamente a mensurar as
nossas ondas cerebrais para saber o que
a gente está pensando é poder tomar uma
ação de acordo com o nosso próprio
pensamento então eu acho que isso é
super interessante e não só o que a
gente está pensando mais o campo mais
fértil era da neurociência onde tem
gente que fica inclusive que em
descobrir o nosso próprio inconsciente
então não só a nossa mente racional mas
o grande objetivo é saber até o que a
gente não sabe
então isso é super interessante e aí
estão cruzando neurociência com games
com toda a parte de um ambiente virtual
né pra que seja então uma uma
experiência mais completa
o segundo princípio que a gente percebe
são as tecnologias cada vez mais
intuitivas
a então até um tempo atrás daquilo que
incomodava né
você tinha que aprender a usar quando
mudava o equipamento sem neve se perdia
hoje cada vez mais a tecnologia vai
ficar meio que imperceptível nas nossas
vidas primeiro puro uma questão também
do do virtual e do real começando assim
é misturar cada vez mais estão óculos
rift era grande vedete deste ano onde
você tem uma imersão 360 completa para
onde olhar acertar no ambiente virtual
outra questão dessa questão da
tecnologia em perceptível é que a
tecnologia vai começar a ficar tão perto
não é só o festival está na nossa
própria pele vai ficar monitorando a
nossa pele da seca tamai mais ou menos
hidratada se a gente está soando quer
dizer quem está nervoso ou seja é e aí
vai poder atuar
imagina isso no campo da medicina então
em vez de ficar cheio de aparelhos
médicos monitorando uma simples tatuagem
um adesivo vai poder trazer todas as
informações e até a gente
todo mundo lá no salto mais alto estava
com o google glass
mas acho que até mesmo o congresso é uma
tecnologia ultrapassada
então o próprio gol afastando uma lente
de contato que fica monitorando também
essas nossas informações como glicose é
pra quem tem questão de diabetes não vai
precisar ficar chorando e obviamente tem
gente já tem gente na china estudando
lentes de contato que vai trazer a
realidade aumentada então se não vai
precisar de óculos apesar de nada só uma
lente de contato ou seja vai ter todas
as informações a ele lá rola um as
palestras principais né então são cinco
dias pelo menos da parte distal e cada
cada dia tem um palestrante principal
no último dia o tema mais interessante é
a questão do mapeamento genético e
também foi falado aqui hoje
o assunto também está aqui tem muita
evidência só que o grande tema é a
democratização desse mapeamento genético
então hoje dá pra fazer por 99 dólares
em uma semana você faz uma amostra de
saliva e você já tem toda a informação é
do seu código genético
e dá pra saber se você vai ter alguma é
vai te ajudar em alguma questão de
doenças congênitas
mas até quem médici puxou mais a mãe mas
o pai né não vai ficar nu no os
objetivos e vai até lá a informação
inclusive é de qual sua origem né então
se a gente vê um cara que que é
brasileiro mas ele tem um código
escandinavo porque ele vem de família
italiana e teve uma invasão nórdica em
1600 na itália então esse tipo de
informação que a gente vai começar a ter
outro ponto um outro ponto interessante
são as tecnologias sensoriais
então cada vez mais a tecnologia vai vai
permitir a gente sentir coisas que antes
eram impossíveis né então mesmo hoje a
gente interage muito com as telas do
ipad do do nosso iphone e hoje ainda é
um você não pode sentir a textura é você
ainda tem aquela tela plana como
interface
na verdade já existe uma tecnologia
chamada tecnologias artísticas e que
você vai estar num num circuito junto
com o equipamento e você vai poder
sentir texturas está nessas telas
digitais não for um mapa por exemplo uma
pacata o gráfico vai poder sentir o
relevo e tecnologia já existe então
qualquer objeto que você for pegar ele
pode ser liso você vai poder sentir uma
textura de um tecido algo assim o ar
o próprio ar também está sendo utilizado
para passar as sensações então já existe
essa tecnologia é muito usada para games
de canhões de ar
então em vez de jogar o kinect que hoje
você não sente nada você efetivamente
vai sentir que está defendendo uma
jogada ou pegar uma bola né ou na
cadeira
então tudo isso vai proporcionar uma
experiência muito mais rica
acho que é a terceira que é muito
interessante a questão de tecnologias
potencializadoras então efetivamente o
uso da tecnologia como uma extensão das
nossas capacidades amplificando o que a
gente pode
z então adiou por exemplo está pensando
nesse interactive table essa mesa
interativa onde uma criança por exemplo
vai desenhar um dinossauro
mas ela que é de algum modo fazer ver
diferentes opções do rabo do dinossauro
que ela pode ter
e aí o própria mesa interativa vai poder
propor então vai usar a criatividade da
criança mas dando opções de escolhas de
de outras formas de se fazerem as coisas
uma das ativações da ibm mais
interessante esse ano era o cognitivo
cumprir o código nativo que o quim ou
seja cozinhar o desvio utilizando uma
tecnologia computacional cognitiva é
então tinham eles chamaram vários chips
mas os chefes
eles usavam ingredientes que eram
comentados nas redes sociais tratos a
que as pessoas comentavam então eles
tinham que e gerando aí outras
combinações inusitadas a proferir serem
um cardápio desse futuro ou seja é
sempre um pensamento de que o homem
tenha criatividade mas o computador pode
oferecer muito mais escolhas então é
isso do que isso que se trata o copo de
tive com o piollin então médico ele vai
continuar por exemplo sendo referência
do tratamento mas numa ficha médica vai
dar milhões de possibilidades de de
diagnóstico ou ddd por exemplo é
medicamentos que muitas vezes ele não
consegue consultar não tem na memória e
finalmente a tecnologia também se
aproximar da própria natureza ea própria
tecnologia se funde com a natureza então
é uma área muito promissora
o pessoal debate vem estudando muito a
questão da bioengenharia onde matéria
orgânica está sendo utilizada é pra
produção de de novos materiais e
estruturas
então aqui por exemplo é uma luminária
uma escultura feita de bichos de seda
então eles conseguem através de luz
calor é coordenar
o o o como um o terceiro dos bichos de
seda criando essas estruturas aqui então
falando de é material feito de bactéria
ou seja é a bactéria se solidificando
como se fosse uma colônia e criando
esses objetos
há aqui estamos falando de cupim
então você joga um líquido e de alguma
maneira esse líquido depois a uma
colônia de cupins vai fazer o trabalho
de desculpe
então essa simbiose acho que mais do que
nunca ela ela vem acontecendo e ii para
questões também de de âmbito até de
preocupação global por exemplo o consumo
de carne é então tinha um tio pessoas lá
a gente participou de um fórum só para
discutir como vai ser a casa do futuro e
aqui falando de uma carne que ela é
cultivada
então não precisa matar os animais e é
solucionar a questão do sofrimento
então essas ongs são os quatro
princípios que a gente vem estudando e
agente identificou então o que vem
acontecendo justamente isso a tecnologia
vem sua humanizando e o que antes era o
homem versus a tecnologia o que a gente
está vendo agora é o homem mais a
tecnologia
então aqui sendo uma faculdade de
telecomunicações de tecnologia
interessante que os projetos que sejam
desenvolvidos aqui que tenham esse olhar
que tem esse pensamento porque é isso
que vem acontecendo daqui pra frente
finaliza com uma frase que a tecnologia
ao se aproximar do homem
ela transforma também a relação do homem
com a própria tecnologia
então espero que essa forma de pensar e
inspire muitos projetos aqui da anatel
obrigada